we've just been hearing from a doctor
they're talking about the fight that the
NHS is putting up to try and get this
virus under control but of course long
term we have to think of a way out of
the lockdown I just wonder what your in
your view is the most likely way out of
the current restrictions that we see
ourselves in well it's not by herd
immunity that's for sure
I think the government's taken the right
path now eventually I think the two-week
lockdown has given the NHS a fighting
chance and I think what we need to do
now is not just wait for the vaccine
what I think will happen is that we'll
get better at testing hopefully we'll
get the protective equipment that the
NHS needs we'll see that curve flat now
so that there's not the kind of
overwhelming pressure on the NHS that
would have happened had we not taken
these measures which would have all
kinds of ramifications because virtually
it would bring the NHS grinding to a
halt and they wouldn't be there to
protect us and then we see this
gradually dying out meet the last
outbreak of this kind
ye the last coronavirus pandemic was
2002 with SARS now it never became a
pandemic actually it was confined to two
place like career and the Far East but
it eventually out you know came to a
halt and I think that will happen here
but you know the kind of discussion and
debate I'm seeing raising its head again
about herd immunity is you put in effect
you put the economy before human lives
and I don't think that's acceptable to
any of any political persuasion now you
of course were health secretary between
2007 and 2009 during the swine flu
pandemic of course coronavirus clover 9
teams far deadlier than that but given
the fact that we have experienced
pandemics before why weren't we better
prepared that is the big question I mean
you say you know it was it ended up
being milder than we expected but it was
the return of
something called h1n1 the last time
we've seen that was Spanish flu in 1918
you know between 500 million it's
calculated a hundred half a billion
people caught it and anywhere between
fifty and a hundred million people died
and it affected people the younger you
were the more likely you were to get it
so it was terrifying and 457 people died
but we were prepared I don't say we were
prepared because it's something great
about a Labour government but all
governments have a risk register and on
conservative government's had a risk
register and on that risk register top
of our risk register was a pandemic we
know they come along there's been three
three every hundred years for the past
three hundred years so we know they're
coming along and we were prepared for it
and so was the my opposite number health
Andrew Leslie prepared for it we had
debated in Parliament the National
pandemic plan we had the equipment set
aside we had everything in preparation
we had something called to help
Protection Agency which vanished in
about 2011 I'm not sure what effect that
has had but I am absolutely amazed how
badly prepared that government is for
this you know number one on our risk
register was this number two was the
kind of terrorist attack that we saw in
Mumbai for the first time you remember
back in 2007 where terrorists just just
ran riot with machine guns and just
mowed people down that had never
happened before so those two things
would talk about risks register we had
dress rehearsals for them when I first
became health secretary in 2007 I walked
straight into a dress rehearsal of how
we would deal with a national with a
pandemic and how we would deal in this
country with the kind of things we're
seeing now and the same time now at the
same time if the government could have
say would argue that this kind of
pandemic would overwhelm any Health
Service many times over and so how could
they have been fully prepared for
something like kovat 19 well because it
is a pandemic and because pend M
whether they are respiratory pandemics
like this one or whether they're flu
based pandemics like swine flu the basic
things you need at the start is
protective equipment for NHS staff that
doesn't change the first thing you need
is the arrangements for testing that
doesn't change to see whether people
have got it or not I actually think the
equipment's more important because that
would stop frontline health service
workers from actually contracting it
testing is just to see whether they've
got it or not you can prepare those
things and you can have those things
waiting face masks which you know I
don't think I don't think the World
Health Organization now the government's
been criticised for not looking looking
down sooner but for many in many ways
they're just following advice that has
been in place for many years I mean you
told a House of Lords committee in 2009
even in a full pandemic people should
only stay at home if they have symptoms
do you still think that's true yes by
and large that's true the difference
here to swine flu is that we have
antiviral drugs that helped with it we
distributed them to people people could
stay at home have what we called a
pandemic buddy someone who wasn't
affected to go and bring those antiviral
drugs to them and it would help them
with the symptoms it wasn't a vaccine
although the vaccine followed pretty
quickly in 2009 when swine flu broke out
so so that kind of help isn't available
here because as I understand it there
are no antiviral drugs that help with it
so if you're ill actually you're more
likely to have to go to seek help from
the NHS but every time someone carrying
this steps out of doors they run the
risk of infecting more people and we
don't quite know what the reproduction
rate is of this ie the number of people
who catch it there's new has it but it's
pretty high I would guess okay and now I
just want to finish the interview by
talking a little bit about labor a new
leader circus Dharma elected in the
first round
very resounding victory for him
of course it's got a huge challenge
ahead bringing labour back from the
worst two feet since 1935 how do you
think labour needs to change oh we need
to get away from this cult that has
taken his over I mean kids absolutely
this is absolutely the first the right
first step we've got someone there who I
think he's capable of leading this party
back to victory but goodness he's got a
hell of a job on his hands and no one
will be listening much to what he's got
to say early on but what he has said is
exactly the right things he's going to
you know be absolutely productive with
the government in in solving this
current crisis the plea for unity
I mean unity is fine when you've
actually got rid of the problem that's
caused the disunity in the first place
I mean momentum are is an organization
devoted to in Tunisia the assigned
warfare we heard from them yesterday
what did they didn't congratulate PAP
Astana they didn't say anything useful
above them will be watching him on his
back all the time and I'm afraid you
know there's no sign that they buried
the weapons and have dedicated
themselves to unity so he has to make
sure that what's happened to us
including anti-semitism which came in
with these far left insurgents into our
party during 2015 that we cleanse
ourselves of those that here stana has
the right people around him and we
return to being a party there for people
of whatever social class in whatever
part of the country pursuing our two
objectives of the eradication of poverty
and greater equality I'm pretty clear
that you're no fan of momentum all
Corbyn ism or widely but how do you
think history will judge jeremy corbyn's
leadership with the Labour Party also
dreadful incapable of leadership now
we've got a leader who is capable of
leadership and we'll be seeing him leave
but this whole concept of leadership is
a problem for sort of far left you know
they believe that everything should be
from the grassroots which means a few
activists pulling the strings
everything is ideologically
related and we'll hear a big litany of
you know why that everything corbin did
was right we'll hear all that you know
we were almost wiped out and if the
wrong person had won that leadership
election it would have been the end of
the Labor Party now we've got a chance
we but it's a chance and it depends an
awful lot on Kirsten as leadership